there are fewer than three weeks to go
before the Iowa caucus and the latest
polls I'm I'm sorry this is distracting
sir what are you doing okay it's really
creepy the way you're staring at me
what's going on Eve accusing me of
something
[Music]
okay was it something I did on the show
if it's something I did in public was it
recently during the holidays something I
did in public during the holidays
wait you know what it might be excuse me
I'm sorry for asking but you think I
could have that bb-8 toy it's the only
thing man son once for Christmas and if
it doesn't get one he'll be so
heartbroken
sure no problem Merry Christmas [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know I get it fine I was way out of
line and I apologize
I'm not the one you need to apologize to
he looks just like you
all right well stick around I'm very
sorry little boy we got a great show
tonight actor comedian Patton Oswalt is
on the show the director of Batman V
Superman dawn of Justice actors here
music is highly suspect gonna perform
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography